hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr dabei seid und
eingeschaltet habt heute kamen die
Meldung das Polen in den nächsten Tagen
vier Kampfjets an die Ukraine liefern
will dabei handelt es sich um Jets vom
Typ MiG 29 aus sowjetischer Produktion
und damit ist Polen jetzt das erste
nato-land das Kampfjet liefert und das
ist ja eine Forderung der Ukraine die
gibt es schon länger über diese
Forderungen und eventuelle Lieferung
wurde bei den westlichen Verbündeten in
den letzten Wochen ja ganz schön viel
diskutiert damit wir alle noch mal einen
Überblick kriegen hat Florian neuhahn
mal zusammengefasst was heute passiert
ist
schon seit Tagen hatten polnische
Regierungsvertreter diesen Schritt
angedeutet Kampfjets in die Ukraine zu
liefern heute ist es der polnische
Präsident du da die bei einem Treffen
mit seinem tschechischen Kollegen der
die Ankündigung macht
in den kommenden Tagen werden wir soweit
ich weiß vier voll einsatzbereite
Flugzeuge in die Ukraine überführen
weitere werden gewartet und vorbereitet
und nach und nach geliefert werden
[Musik]
es geht um Mick 29 alte Kampfflugzeuge
sowjetischer Bauart der Vorteil
ukrainische Piloten kennen sich mit dem
System aus könnten die Jets daher
schnell nutzen die meisten der
polnischen Kampfjets stammen aus alten
Beständen der Nationalen Volksarmee der
DDR wurden wie hier Anfang der 2000er
Jahre von Deutschland an Polen übergeben
genau solche Jets aus alten DDR
Beständen so berichtet der polnische
Präsident du da heute würden nun an die
Ukraine geliefert dafür aber müsste
Deutschland als Herkunftsland zustimmen
doch der deutsche Verteidigungsminister
weiß am Nachmittag von nichts ich war
bislang keine Bestätigung aus Polen dass
das passiert ist ich kenne die
medienmeldung aber keine Bestätigung
dass das tatsächlich die Absicht ist und
wann und ich habe auch insbesondere
keine Bestätigung darüber dass es Mix
sind aus alten DDR-Beständen Kampfjet
für die Ukraine es ist eine neue Stufe
der militärischen Unterstützung des
Westens doch die Ankündigung aus Polen
lässt heute noch einige Fragen offen
ja wir haben es gerade gehört die
Zustimmung aus Deutschland sei nicht
erforderlich für diese Jets sagt Polen
weil die eben aus Tschechien sein wir
wollen heute trotzdem mal drauf gucken
was sagt eigentlich Deutschland was hat
Berlin zu dieser Meldung was sagen die
anderen Nato-Partner insbesondere der
größte Nato-Partner USA und wie
verändern diese Jets jetzt den Krieg was
bringen diese Kampfjets darüber wollen
wir hier heute sprechen und diskutieren
zum einen mit unserer Korrespondentin in
Berlin schakunda benaji mit unserem
Korrespondenten in Washington Elmar Tier
Wissen und mit dem militär-experten Syke
Neitzel und natürlich wie immer auch mit
euch da draußen die gerade zuschauen
habt ihr Fragen an unsere
Korrespondentin oder an den
militär-experten oder wollt ihr einfach
mal eure Meinung zum Thema mit uns
teilen dann tut das gerne direkt hier im
Youtube Chat oder per E-Mail an ZDF
heute - live at zdf.de und jetzt gucken
wir erstmal auf die Reaktion in Berlin
und das machen wir gemeinsam mit
shakunda benaji die uns zugeschaltet ist
hallo Herr unterlag hallo schönen guten
Abend
ja wir haben heute diese Meldung
empfangen du bist gerade in Berlin gibt
es denn schon Reaktionen aus dem
politischen Berlin aus der
Bundesregierung auf diese Meldung na so
richtig viel kann die Bundesregierung da
momentan noch gar nicht zu sagen denn
bei denen gibt es einfach momentan noch
sehr sehr viele Fragezeichen hinter
dieser Ankündigung da stellt sich vor
allem die Frage was genau hat der
polnische Präsident gemeint um welche
Kampfflugzeuge handelt es sich woher
kommen die ursprünglich und muss
Deutschland zustimmen oder nicht also
wir haben es ja schon gehört dass der
polnische Präsident gesagt hat dass da
geht zum alte ddr-bestände er hat aber
zugleich in der Ankündigung gesagt dass
sein Flugzeuge die in den 90er Jahren
übernommen worden sein und da kamen dann
gleich Zweifel auf denn der direkte
Austausch zwischen Deutschland und Polen
den gab es erst 2003 mit einem
entsprechenden Abkommen also direkt auf
direktem Wege können die sozusagen nicht
von Deutschland abgegeben worden sein
dann gab es die Vermutung dass es sich
um tschechische Flugzeuge handelt und
wir haben damals
Verteidigungsministerium und dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium nachgefragt
wie viel weiß man da jetzt und man prüft
eben noch man sagt das ist in solchen
Fällen gar nicht so einfach zu
beantworten da muss ich ganz genau
anschauen wo kommt das Flugzeug
ursprünglich her die Frage ist momentan
noch offen
ja du sagst es aktuell liegt also keine
Anfrage aus Polen vor ist die denn zu
erwarten bzw wenn wann wäre die denn zu
erwarten ja das ist das ist das große
große Fragezeichen wenn diese Flugzeuge
tatsächlich ursprünglich aus alten DDR
Beständen sind dann müsste Berlin
tatsächlich zustimmen das ist egal ob
die dann zwischendurch in Tschechien
gewesen sind oder nicht das ist ja auch
ein ganz interessanter Aspekt es gibt
eine sogenannte endverbleibsklausel
damit solche Flugzeuge und Kampfmittel
die aus Deutschland kommen nicht in
irgendwo hin geliefert werden und diese
end verbleibsklausel die erlischt auch
nicht egal wie oft es weitergegeben wird
also das gilt es jetzt erstmal zu klären
und natürlich abzuwarten ob Polen sich
tatsächlich noch mit einem Antrag meldet
es wäre nicht das allererste Mal dass
das nicht passiert man hat sich hier
heute sehr schnell daran erinnert das
Polen auch schon einmal die Lieferung
von Kampfpanzern angekündigt hat und das
so formuliert hat als ob es in den
nächsten Tagen und Wochen bevorstünde
dann hat man hier in Berlin auf einen
Antrag gewartet und der kam nach
Aussagen die wir heute gehört haben dann
später nicht also es ist noch gar nicht
klar ob Polen dann tatsächlich auch
Nägeln mit Köpfen macht ganz klar ist
das Polen zu den allerersten gehört hat
die schon zu Kriegsbeginn gesagt haben
die Ukraine braucht Kampfflugzeuge und
lasst uns Kampfflugzeuge dieses Typus
doch liefern damals gab es große
Widerstände unter anderem aus den USA
die gesagt haben da ist das
eskalationsrisiko viel zu hoch und man
sieht jetzt gerade an den aktuellen
Reaktionen
aus NATO-Kreisen hören wir dass die USA
da gar keine so großen Einwände mehr hat
wie sich da auch die Diskussion
verschiebt und auch als wir heute
nachgefragt haben in Berlin waren die
Reaktionen nicht mehr so ablehnend
Rundweg ablehnend wie wir es noch im
vergangenen Jahr gehört hätten also da
verschiebt sich momentan in der
Diskussion ein wenig was
okay also auch eine sehr spezielle
Reaktion jetzt auf einen polnisches
verlauten das gab es wohl schon mal und
da lag dann auch gar kein Antrag vor
lass uns mal davon ausgehen es kommt
jetzt noch zu so einem Antrag der dann
eingeht in Berlin wie wahrscheinlich
wäre es denn dann dass Deutschland ja
sagen würde also in dem Fall dass Polen
alte DDR Flugzeuge Kampfjets senden
wollen würde ganz genau kann man das
heute noch nicht sagen aber man kann ja
sehen wie jetzt die Reaktionen hier sind
wäre es absolut ausgeschlossen dann
hätten wir heute bei unserem Nachfragen
schon Hinweise darauf gekommen dass es
da eine rote Linie gibt es war ja lange
Zeit so das ist aus der Bundesregierung
hieß es war Kampfflugzeuge sollten wir
auf gar keinen Fall liefern solche
Äußerungen haben wir hier schon länger
nicht mehr gehört in Berlin es ist
auffällig in der Kommunikation der
Bundesregierung dass sie zumindest eben
in der Kommunikation die roten Linien
aufgehoben hat da wird nichts mehr
ausgeschlossen ich meine es war Robert
Habeck der auch gesagt hat wir wollen
gar nichts mehr kategorisch ausschließen
wenn es um Anlieferungen an die Ukraine
geht den Bundeskanzler ist es immer
wichtig gewesen zu sagen bevor
Deutschland etwas liefert muss es sich
einigen mit Bündnispartnern aber das
andere Länder
Mittel liefern können Kampf mit liefern
können wenn sie das selber für nötig
halten das ist auch schon mehrfach in
der Diskussion hier gefallen in Berlin
also halte ich es auch nicht für
gänzlich ausgeschlossen dass das sich
Berlin hier am Ende nicht verweigern
würde wenn Polen tatsächlich diese
Kampfflugzeuge liefern wollte ich glaube
es wird jetzt in der Debatte im weiteren
sehr viel darum gehen ob eine solche
Lieferung von alten Kampfflugzeugen
tatsächlich einen qualitativen
Unterschied machen würden also ob es das
Kriegsgeschehen in der Ukraine
wesentlich beeinflussen könnte der
nächste Schritt der dann folgen würde
wäre vermutlich in der öffentlichen
Debatte die Forderung auch nach
Lieferung kam von Kampfflugzeugen neuer
Bauart und damit würde sich die
Bundesregierung deutlich schwerer tun
ja also wir sehen es sind noch ganz
viele Fragen offen am heutigen Tag
erstmal vielen dank dir schreib Nutella
für dein input
und wir wollen jetzt den Blick mal etwas
weiten weil diese Entscheidung
Überlieferungen an die Ukraine über die
wir hier bei ZDF heute live ja schon
ganz oft gesprochen haben die sind ja
innerhalb des NATO-Bündnisses oft
abgesprochen und wie da reagiert wird
insbesondere beim größten Nato-Partner
den USA darüber spreche ich jetzt mit
unserem Korrespondenten in Washington
Elmar Telefon
also nach Deutschland
ja seit heute ist klar der erste
Nato-Partner liefert Kampfjets du sitzt
ja gerade in Washington wie reagiert
denn jetzt der größte Nato-Partner USA
darauf
ja es gibt eine ganz klare Linie die
offenbar aus dem Weißen Haus vorgegeben
ist weil wir hören sie auf verschiedenen
Podien heute von verschiedenen
Gesprächspartnern wir haben aber vorhin
selber mit John Kirby gesprochen
gemeinsam mit anderen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das ist der Sprecher des
Nationalen Sicherheitsrats und der hat
im Grunde genommen die Linie dann auch
formuliert er hat gesagt das ist die
souveräne Entscheidung eines Landes
diese Kampfjets zu liefern das
respektieren die USA das ist der eine
teil und das ist natürlich schon eine
Veränderung der Position zu dem was wir
in den letzten Monaten so gehört haben
und das zweite was er dann sagt sagte
das hat keinen Einfluss auf die
Entscheidungsfindung der USA ob Sie
selber auch bereit sind moderne
Kampfjets zu liefern da ist ja mal die
Rede von F16 Kampfflugzeugen die die USA
liefern könnten vielleicht auch andere
Nato-Partner also die Entscheidung
Polens ist keine Vorwegnahme dieser
Entscheidung die USA bilden zurzeit zwar
zwei ukrainische Piloten hier in den USA
in Arizona aus aber nur auf
Flugsimulatoren auf F16 Kampfflugzeugen
weil sie mal feststellen wollen wie viel
wissen die denn eigentlich wie schnell
könnten die möglicherweise das Fliegen
dieser Jets erlernen aber das bedeutet
eben nicht das hat schon Kirby noch mal
sehr klar gemacht dass dann auch die USA
in den nächsten Wochen schon bereit sein
würden F16 Kampfjets in die Ukraine zu
liefern
kannst du den aktuell einschätzen was
passieren müsste aus US sich damit
dieser FC F16 Jets geliefert werden
würde
ich glaube was wir hier erleben ist ja
eine graduelle Veränderung innerhalb der
Nato und das hat den erster Linie damit
zu tun was in der Ukraine passiert man
hat jetzt über mehr als ein Jahr doch
eine sehr große Unterstützung für die
Ukraine gegeben aber es hat noch nicht
dazu geführt dass Moskau in irgendeiner
Form von seinen Maximalforderungen
abgewichen wäre und das bedeutet dass
die Nato-Partner ganz offenbar gestern
auch wieder in der Kontaktgruppe aber
auch in den letzten Wochen schon
miteinander darüber geredet haben was
wäre eigentlich zu tun damit Putin sich
bewegt und dazu gehört Gelände Gewinne
innerhalb der Ukraine also Teile der
Ostukraine
zurückzuerobern und deswegen hat man ja
in den letzten Monaten auch die
Lieferung von Kampfpanzern Leopard 2
aber auch Abrams Panzern beschlossen
waren die dann jeweils da geliefert
werden wenn wir noch sehen aber das
scheint wichtig zu sein um Putin und die
russischen Streitkräfte mehr unter Druck
zu setzen und man ist noch nicht so weit
dass man sagt man braucht modernste
Flugzeuge Kampfflugzeuge dafür weil es
geht in erster Linie um Territorium
zurück zu erobern im Osten der Ukraine
es geht noch nicht um die Krim um die
Halbinsel sondern es geht nur um anderes
Territorium und das kann man erreichen
einerseits natürlich mit dem schon
gelieferten zweitens vielleicht auch mit
weiterreichenden Raketen auch da
erwarten wir in den nächsten Wochen eine
Weiterentwicklung vielleicht eine
Entscheidung diese zu liefern und dann
eben auch die Lieferung von Kampfjets
die aber ich sag mal einfacher für die
ukrainischen Piloten zu fliegen sind und
für die auch der Nachschub spricht
Ersatzteile etc gewährleistet werden
können das wäre für modernere Kampfjets
wie den F16 sehr sehr schwierig
Wir haben hier gerade zu diesem
nato-gefüge was er jetzt im Zuge dieser
Lieferung immer im Fokus ist meine Frage
aus der Community an dich und zwar fragt
Sven Odendahl auf Facebook ist das nicht
wieder ein Zeichen für die Spaltung
innerhalb der NATO die schon bei den
panzerlieferung deutlich zu Tage traten
ich glaube man will genau das vermeiden
was bei den Panzerlieferungen nämlich
geschehen ist dass am Ende man irgendwie
immer den Finger auf den anderen zeigen
konnte und dann wurde ja die
Formulierung gefunden wir brauchen einen
strategischen Gleichschritt das hat ja
dann hier in Washington vor ein paar
Wochen auch Joe Biden gesagt als der
Bundeskanzler hier war der hat die
gleichen Worte dann auch gebraucht aber
im Grunde genommen war man da hier in
Washington schon der in dieser Haltung
zu sagen die Deutschen hätten das
eigentlich auch souverän alleine
entscheiden können dass sie Leopard 2
Panzer liefern und es hätte man nicht
abhängig machen müssen von den USA warum
eben weil man zu dem Schluss gekommen
ist es ist jetzt mehr erforderlich in
den nächsten Wochen und Monaten also
einen Schritt weiter zu gehen die
Ukraine noch mehr zu unterstützen damit
der Punkt kommt an dem aufladimir Putin
an Interesse daran haben könnte von den
Maximalforderungen abzuweichen und dazu
gehört zum Beispiel die Nachschubwege
der russischen Streitkräfte zur Krim
abzuschneiden und das kann man nicht nur
mit reinen Bodentruppen dazu braucht man
weiterreichende Raketen dazu braucht man
natürlich auch Kampfflugzeuge nur eines
wollen alle vermeiden auch die USA ganz
voran sie wollen nicht direkt in den
Krieg hineingezogen werden also sie
wollen auch nicht dass diese
Kampfflugzeuge dann verwendet werden um
Ziele auf russischem Boden anzugreifen
das wäre die rote Linie die man
sicherlich vor diesen Lieferungen
gegenüber der ukrainischen Regierung
sehr klar gemacht hat
wir haben hier auf jeden Fall eine Menge
Fragen aus der Community ich habe hier
noch mal eine von Stefan auf YouTube und
der fragt kommt diese Kampfjet Koalition
überhaupt noch rechtzeitig zum Tragen um
der ukrainischen Frühjahr ist Offensive
den Weg zu ebenen bzw welche Rolle
spielen Kampfjets im Gefecht der
verbundenen Waffen kannst du uns dazu
sagen
ja keine ganz so große muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen wir haben es ja in
erster Linie tatsächlich mit einem
Bodenkrieg zu tun und dazu braucht man
das vorhin beschriebene
Artilleriegeschütze man die auch
weiterreichende Raketen möglicherweise
abfeiern können und dann eben auch
Panzer und gepanzerte Fahrzeuge da hat
man ja schon einiges geliefert die
Kampfflugzeuge sind vielleicht in erster
Linie dann dazu da um den Vormarsch
abzusichern vielleicht eben auch dabei
zu helfen die Nachschubwege zu zerstören
für die russischen Streitkräfte aber man
muss klar sagen die russische Luftwaffe
hätte eine Haushöhe Überlegenheit auch
jetzt schon hat sie die eigentlich
interessanterweise werden die
Kampfflugzeuge der russischen
Streitkräfte gar nicht so häufig
eingesetzt wie man vielleicht erwarten
könnte weil es eben nicht darum geht den
Krieg auch aus russischer Sicht irgendwo
anders hin als auf den ukrainischen
Boden und den Vormarsch zu tragen das
erledigt man lieber mit Raketen weil man
dann natürlich auch ein geringeres
Risiko eingeht und auch aus
amerikanischer und NATO Sicht gibt es
kein Interesse daran dass eben
tatsächlich am Ende ukrainische
Kampfflugzeuge von denen ist nur noch
wenige gibt zur Zeit also diese auch zu
nutzen um den Krieg weit auch auf
russisches Territorium zu tragen
und wir haben hier abschließend noch
eine Frage die sich auch direkt an Dich
adressiert und zwar fragt extract of
pineal glant auf YouTube eine Frage an
Herrn tewesen wie könnte sich die
Unterstützung der USA für die Ukraine
ändern wenn Trump wieder Präsident würde
ja dass das große Fragezeichen was hier
existiert Trump war ja wie wir es nennen
ein transaktionaler Präsident der also
immer einen Deal gemacht hat wenn er
irgendein Vorteil daraus schlagen kann
wenn Trump wieder Präsident würde müsste
man damit rechnen dass er irgendein Deal
macht mit Wladimir Putin zu Ungunsten
der Ukraine so ist eigentlich die Leser
hier ganz super spannend ist gerade das
ja einer der möglichen
Präsidentschaftskandidaten der
Republikaner Ron Design ist diesen Krieg
in der Ukraine als Gebiets Disput
zwischen Ukraine und Russland bezeichnet
hat wo Amerika eigentlich gar keine
großen interessenvertreten sollte also
auch wenn ein dezant ist gewählt würde
müsste man sich darauf einrichten dass
die USA nicht mehr die Unterstützung für
die Ukraine geben wie wir sie bisher
erlebt haben und das ist glaube ich der
Grund weshalb die Amerikaner ein voran
die beiden Administration auch Druck
machen möglichst voranzukommen also
Geländegewinne für die Ukraine zu
erzielen die Unterstützung noch
auszubauen in den nächsten Wochen und
Monaten damit man hoffentlich noch im
Verlauf dieses Jahres zu einem Punkt
kommt an dem Wladimir Putin bereit ist
von seinen Maximalforderungen abzurücken
so viel erstmal zum Blick in die USA
vielen Dank Elmar dass du meine und die
Frage der Community so beantwortet hast
vielen Dank
ja wir haben jetzt einmal den Blick auf
die deutsche Bundesregierung geworfen
wir haben zum größten Nato-Partner USA
geblickt lasst uns jetzt noch mal den
Blick in die Ukraine werfen und über den
wirklichen Einfluss sprechen den diese
Jet Lieferung jetzt auf den Krieg haben
und was sie auch Perspektive für den
weiteren Kriegsverlauf bedeuten könnten
und das machen wir gemeinsam mit
Militärexperte Sönke Neitzel hallo Herr
Neitzel
wenn ihr Fragen an Herr Neitzel habt
oder eure Meinung mit uns teilen wollt
dann macht das gerne weiterhin hier im
Youtube Chat oder per E-Mail an ZDF
heute - live at zdf.de hernalse das ist
eine Frage die haben sich heute bestimmt
viele gestellt wir hören jetzt ja
erstmal nur von vier Jets was für ein
Einfluss haben diese vier Jets jetzt
wirklich auf den Ukraine Krieg
naja vier Jets das kann man sich ja
vorstellen haben natürlich keinen großen
Einfluss aber es ist ein politisches
Zeichen wenn sie dann wirklich geliefert
werden wo man abwarten manchmal nimmt
Polen ja den Mund ein wenig voll aber
gehen wir mal davon auszuwehren
geliefert da ist das glaube ich ein
Zeichen ein erster Schritt und man muss
glaube ich kein sehr sein um zu
prognostizieren dass dann weitere mit 29
Folgen werden und letztlich geht's darum
um die Frage hat die Ukraine überhaupt
noch eine Luftwaffe kann sie in der
dritten Dimension der Luft durchführen
und das wäre meiner Sicht ein wichtiges
Zeichen
jetzt von Polen angeführt ähm vom Westen
dass man sagt ja wir erhalten eine eine
ukrainische Luftwaffe das ist seine nach
wie vor und nicht vielleicht die
allergrößte Wichtigkeit aber es ist
wichtig dass sich die Ukraine auch in
der Luft verteidigen kann und dazu
braucht sie nicht 29
sie haben das eben schon angesprochen
dritte Dimension also quasi der Luftraum
in so einem Krieg können Sie uns mal
einen Überblick darüber geben welche
Rolle spielen denn überhaupt Kampfjets
bisher in diesem Krieg auf der
ukrainischen Seite und auf der
russischen Seite
ist Herr tewesen hat es auch schon
angesprochen vorhin dass wir eigentlich
davon ausgegangen sind dass die
russische Luftwaffe in der Lage sein
würde die Luft verschafft über der
Ukraine sehr schnell zu erkämpfen und
dann auch einen hohen Einfluss auf die
Bodenkämpfe hat weil die die technische
und die zahlenmäßig Überlegenheit der
russischen Norm war also die Ukraine
hatte vielleicht ja also 150g Flugzeuge
als der Krieg ausbrach und die Russen
haben vielleicht die zehnfache zahlen
aber die Ukraine haben sich sehr
geschickt verteidigt haben also in der
Nacht vor dem Angriff ihre Flugzeuge
zurückgezogen nach Westen verlegt sie
haben den Krieg in der Luft vor allen
Dingen mit Boden Luft Raketen geführt
und das hat so erheblichen Verlusten der
russischen geführt und es gelang eben
nicht diese auszuschalten und auch der
Westen liefert auch Deutschland Raketen
das heißt der Krieg in der dritten
Dimension in der Luft wird vor allen
Dingen mit Raketen geführt
und trotzdem gibt es immer noch Einsätze
nicht so sehr zahlreich also niedrigen
dreistelligen Bereich
an der gesamten Front pro Tag
also das sind letztlich im Vergleich zu
den Weltkriegen oder so sind das ist es
relativ wenig aber die Ukraine fliegen
eben auch noch immer wenn auch weniger
einsetzt aber sie sind da und die
wenigen ukrainischen Jagdflugzeuge ist
noch gibt sind auch eine Gefahren für
die Russen also darum geht es letztlich
nicht es ist ein gewisser Weise kann man
sagen ein Leben kriegshop Platz also der
Kampf mit Flugzeugen in der klassischen
Form aber er ist da und die Russen
benutzen ihre Nummer vor allen Dingen
dafür um über den eigenen Flughäfen auch
zu steigen also im russischen
Territorium und von dort aus Raketen
Langstreckenraketen in die Ukraine
abzuschließen
wir haben ja auch direkt eine Frage aus
der Community zu äh Raketen und der
Verbindung zu Kampfjets und zwar fragt
Markus auf Youtube sind die polnischen
Mix über die wir jetzt gerade sprechen
Fake auch am Rahmen oder ähnliche
weitreichende Raketen zu verschließen
bislang sollen die Ukraine nur alte
luft-
die die mit 29 sind ja also es gibt sie
können auch bestückt werden mit mit
Raketen der NATO mit modernen Raketen
diese polnischen mit 29 sind alle
abgedatet worden also das nicht mehr die
Flugzeuge die die sagen 1988
an die nva-woche geliefert worden sind
und die ukrainischen Streitkräfte sind
in einem erstaunlichen Ausmaß in der
Lage auch zu improvisieren und alle
möglichen Raketen dann an ihren an ihre
Flugzeuge zu helfen der Hauptweg aber
dieser mit 29 soweit ist das Überblick
ist allerdings wirklich die Luft
Verteidigung
allerdings auch eine größere Entfernung
also jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht der
kurvenkampf wie man das vielleicht aus
den Weltkriegen noch im Kopf hat der
Kampf mit Luft Raketen und da werden Sie
sicherlich in wichtigen in wichtigen
Einfluss haben der nicht zu groß ist
aber immerhin man erhält wirklich schon
sagte damit die Kampffähigkeit in der
dritten Dimension
eine Sorge die diese Debatte in den
letzten Wochen um diese Lieferung von
Kampfjets ja immer begleitet hat war ja
ob die Ukraine solche Kampfjets
theoretisch auch nutzen könnte um
russische Gebiete angreifen zu können
wie realistisch ist das denn generell
und überhaupt mit diesen mit 29
ja und jetzt ist nicht gleich gett wobei
man natürlich sagen muss man kann mit
auch mit mit 29 alles Mögliche tun es
ist eigentlich ein Jagdflugzeug aber
natürlich wird es auch Möglichkeiten
geben da irgendwie im Bombe oder eben
auch eine Mittelstreckenrakete oder eine
Rakete mit der man auf Russisch System
wirken kann da drunter zu packen sehr
sinnvoll ist das bei der mit 29 nicht in
das macht man eben mit jagdbon also mit
27 23
Flugzeugen die von den die Ukraine auch
ein paar haben ich glaube bei der mit 29
geht es vor allen Dingen um die Stärkung
der Luft Verteidigung
darum glaube ich geht dass man das noch
machen kann dass man russische Flugzeuge
noch bekämpfen kann darum geht es hier
und nicht darum jetzt irgendwie ich weiß
nicht in der Nähe von Moskau Ziele
anzugreifen das werden die Ukraine
weiter mit Drohnen machen
wir nochmal eine Frage zu generellen
Symbolik dieser Ankündigung von heute
und zwar fragt es gibt mg auf Youtube
könnte die Entscheidung Kampfjets zu
liefern eine Antwort Polens auf die
gestrigen Verhaftung russischer Spione
sein
das glaube ich nicht also wir alle
schauen der polnischen Regierung nicht
in den Kopf aber ich glaube dass das
eine diese Lieferung der mit 29 ist eine
Sache die ja ganz ganz lang schon
vorbereitet wird wir erinnern uns daran
dass schon wenige Monate nach dem
Ausbruch des Krieges das schon mal
überlegt wurde diese mit 29 über
Rammstein an die Ukraine zu liefern das
haben die Amerikaner damals abgelehnt
und es ist eigentlich eher die
Notwendigkeit
jetzt die Ukraine haben immer weniger
Flugzeuge immer weniger flugbereit die
Notwendigkeit jetzt Flugzeuge zu liefern
und überhaupt eine ukrainische Luftwaffe
zu erhalten ist jetzt eben viel größer
als als vor zehn Monaten und das ist
glaube ich jetzt der Schritt den man
machen will und das ist glaube ich auch
ein symbolischer Schritt jetzt ähm weil
es auch darum geht innerhalb Europas
immer deutlich zu machen wer ist der
Nase vorne also bei diesen ganzen Waffen
Lieferungen es ist ja leider nicht nur
so dass man irgendwie geschlossen ist
und die EU gemeinsam
lassen Sie uns mal den Blick so ein
bisschen Weiten von Polen auf die
anderen westlichen Bündnispartner man
fühlt sich also ein bisschen erinnert an
diese Debatte damals um die Leopard 2
Panzer wo auch Polen vorangegangen ist
und dann sind nach und nach andere
nachgezogen ist das jetzt eine ähnliche
Situation hier fragt auch jemand aus der
Community Daniel wü auf Youtube mich
würde interessieren wie denn die
Bestände an Kampfjet sind in Europa die
für die Ukraine sofort nutzbar wären
und auf diese Frage direkt zu antworten
so sehr viel sind das nicht also die
Polen haben
wenn ich das richtig so knapp 30 mit 29
davon sind aber auch einige Trainer
Trainings Flugzeuge und die Slowaken
haben so ungefähr zehn das ist zunächst
der mit 29 bestand immer unmittelbar
liefern kann andere Staaten haben ihre
mit 29 stillgelegt weil die eben aus den
80er Jahren kommen im Design es gibt
weltweit noch andere Nationen die mit 29
fliegen z.B aber das ist relativ
unwahrscheinlich dass man außerhalb
Europas jetzt kann Flugzeuge in die
Ukraine geliefert also das ist relativ
begrenzt und auch deswegen haben wir ja
schon eine Debatte also auch diese das
in Polen und sich Slowakei alle ihre mit
29 liefern würden reden über 30 auch die
werden irgendwann kaputt sein und wenn
man will dass die Ukraine in der
Luftwaffe hat wenn man will dass sie
sich in der Luft verteidigen kann dann
wird man nicht unbedingt irgendwann
und deswegen glaube ich beginnen die
Amerikaner auch schon hier mit der
Pilotenausbildung weil das ist dann noch
mal ein anderer step da muss man dann
Piloten länger Schulen als es bei der
mit 29 davon ist also die Bestände mit
29 begrenzt
das heißt aber auch wie hier in
Deutschland hätten eigentlich gar keine
Jets die in die Ukraine gehen könnten
naja also das ist eine politische
Entscheidung liefern kann man natürlich
alles was fliegen die Deutschen die
deutschen kriegen Tornado das Ding ist
noch deutlich älter als als sie mit 29
in Jagdbomber das empfiehlt sich
wirklich nicht weil dann also der ist
sozusagen
Klebeband zusammengehalten wenn ich es
jetzt ein bisschen salopp sage die
modernsten deutschen jetzt sind die
Eurofighter
in einer multirollenfunktion
Jagdflugzeug aber auch in jagt Bomber
aber das empfiehlt sich nicht ist
empfiehlt sich wirklich die F16 die F 16
ist am meisten verkaufte
Flugzeug seiner Art über 4000 mal gebaut
und wird von ich weiß nicht 25 Nationen
noch geflogen also wenn man das im
Hinblick auch auf Wartung und so weiter
werden
eine Menge starten dann ist die F16 wenn
man so will der Leopard 2 der Luft
es gibt hier auch Fragen aus der
Community die sich auf die russische
Seite beziehen und zwar fragt Thomas
zachmaier auf Facebook welche Kampfjets
stehen auf russischer Seite diesen
Fliegern gegenüber und sind diese
überlegen
ja die Russen also wie gesagt 29 kommt
aus den 80er Jahren und die Russen haben
mittlerweile natürlich und ist dann auch
mehrfach abgedatet worden nicht also die
die heutige mit 29 hat mit einer von den
80er Jahren nicht mehr so schrecklich
viel zu tun mit anderer Technik
natürlich drin aber wussten haben
Kampfflugzeuge Jagdflugzeuge an
jagdbombe die wesentlich moderner sind
und ähm es kommt ja sehr stark darauf an
welche Raketen welche Luft und Raketen
man vor allen Dingen hat welche
Radargeräte ähm und da ist die
miteinander und 20 in dieser Form auch
wenn ich abgedeckt worden ist die
modernsten jetzt schon unterlegen also
das ist alles kleine Bausteine einer
Kampfkraft und wir sehen in diesem Krieg
er ist einerseits mit Hightech ähm
geführt aber auch mit relativ alten
Waffen das ist eine ganz coole Mischung
und diese mit 29 werden jetzt nicht der
Ukraine die Luft Herrschaft über dem
Schlachtfeld zurückerobern aber sie sind
ein kleiner Baustein um auch russische
Flugzeuge zu bedrohen um es der Ukraine
ein Stück leichter zu machen diesen
Krieg durchzuhalten
wir haben hier noch eine Frage die sich
auch auf Russland bezieht von Streambox
auf Youtube wie würde den Russland
reagieren wenn der Krieg auf das
russische Staatsgebiet ausgeweitet
werden würde also wenn quasi die Ukraine
in Russland einmarschiert halten Sie das
für realistisch
nein das halte ich nicht für realistisch
denn wir überlegen uns dazu zeigen wie
ist es überhaupt möglich dass die
Ukraine eine gegen Offensive macht und
wir diskutieren ob es überhaupt möglich
ist dass die Ukraine russische
Streitkräfte von ihrem Territorium
vertreibt und die meisten Experten auch
ich würde sagen na ja also die
hoffentlich schaffen dass die Ukraine
eine gegen Offensive zu machen das wäre
schon ein echter Erfolg wenn sie die
Landbrücke durchschneiden würden also
wenn das Schwarze Meer erreichen eine
Rückeroberung allen Tiere thoriums
halte ich im jetzigen Zeitpunkt er
verunrealistisch und erst recht ein
einmal
nach Russland und davon spricht auch
niemand es ist schon ein sehr
ambitioniertes Ziel überhaupt den Stand
vom 24 Februar wieder zu erreichen und
alles andere wäre rein utopisch dafür
reichen die Kräfte nicht außer das ist
glaube ich nicht das Ziel der Ukraine
kann man den gerade schon absehen wie
Russland wie Moskau auf diese
Ankündigung heute reagieren wird
naja wenn sie dann wirklich kommt noch
ist es ja sagen nur verbal wenn diese
vier Flugzeuge wirklich geliefert werden
dann ist es relativ klar wie Russland
reagieren oder Russland wird sagen das
ist eine weitere Eskalation damit wird
empfohlen Kriegspartei und so weiter und
so weiter so hat Russland immer reagiert
und erfolgt ist nicht da drauf jetzt
kann man natürlich nie sicher sein also
keiner kann gut in den Kopf schauen aber
es ist natürlich
genauso wie es unwahrscheinlich war das
Putin jetzt nennenswert eskaliert wegen
50 Panzern ist es natürlich genauso
Unwahrscheinlichkeit eskaliert wegen
wegen viel mit 29 aber er wird natürlich
die Ängste die gerade in Deutschland
vorhanden sind weiterführen solche
Kommentare mitgeben ich halte es verrate
unwahrscheinlich das ganz konkret darauf
etwas folgt
darüber gesprochen dass Polen aktuell
nur die Mix äh liefern möchte die sie
von Tschechien bekommen haben und dass
wenn alte DDR Mix geliefert werden
sollten dann müsste ein Antrag in
Deutschland gestellt werden und hier
fragte es wenn Oden da noch mal auf
Facebook welche Strafen drohen denn wenn
sich Polen nicht an diese Antrag sondern
diese Anfrage Pflicht halten würde
ja also das ich halte es für relativ
unrealistisch immer an jetzt Polen würde
diese Jets einfach liefern dass die
Deutschen dann
also ein ja es müsste man ja erstmal vor
Gericht ziehen müsste ein Gericht diese
Strafen festlegen es halte ich für sehr
sehr unwahrscheinlich also die
Verhältnis Verhältnis der Deutschen und
Polen ist schon sehr angespannt
das ist ja schon lange Vorgeschichte
dieser Krieg man fühlte sich im Übergang
holen mehrfach aber auch jetzt bei der
ausbildungsmission bei der EU
ausbildungsmission wo ja Polen und
Deutsche zusammenarbeiten nächstes
hinter den Kulissen ganz gewaltig und
ich glaube dass die Bundesregierung
darüber ja also sie würde öffentlich
glaube ich nicht kein großes Fass
ausmachen würde hinter den Kulissen
versuchen auch mal amerikanischer
Unterstützung und den Polen klar zu
machen das ist so nicht geht aber ich
glaube nicht dass das ähm
öffentlich gegen Polen in einem
wesentlichen Weise verwendet wurde weil
es geht ja auch darum dass dass die EU
weiter geschlossen bleibt und diese
Geschlossenheit ist ja auch ein
wichtiges Kriegsmittel ein wichtiges
Zeichen Richtung Russland und jede Frau
anders des öffentlichen Streits sehr
wenn der kontraproduktiv und ich glaube
auch nicht dass Polen diese mit 29 ohne
eine deutsche Genehmigung liefern würden
und lassen sie uns abschließend noch mal
so ein bisschen einen Ausblick geben
hier gibt es eine Frage von Lucky Luke
auf Youtube für wie realistisch halten
sie ist das auch andere Nationen mit
ihrer Entscheidung Kampfflugzeuge zu
senden nachziehen werden nach heute
also ich weiß dass die Slowakei das ähm
sehr lange diskutiert dass auch das
slowakische Außenminister dafür ist dass
slowakische Verteidigungsminister ist
aber wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe
Parlamentsentscheidung und das Slowakei
also ähm aber das Slowakei zumindest die
Regierung will das auch tun und es geht
letztlich wirklich zurzeit nur um diese
beiden starten weil nur die mit 29 haben
und ich glaube einem Lieferung von F 16
im steht zur Zeit nicht an meines Wissen
in den USA jetzt aktuell nicht
diskutiert auch in anderen Staaten aber
wir werden das glaube ich ähm erleben
also ich glaube kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass das nie erfolgen wird
denn die Ukraine wird weiter Flugzeuge
in diesem Kampf auch verlieren und es
ist ein Interesse des Westens überhaupt
eine ukrainische Luftwaffe zu erhalten
überhaupt die Möglichkeit den Ukraine zu
geben sich auch mit Flugzeugen in der
Luft verteilen
ja und abschließend für sie noch ein
speziell an sie gerichtetes Lob von
Feierabend eins der auf Youtube sagt
Herr neitzer ist eine gute Wahl für die
Beurteilung der Lage also in dem Sinne
vielen Dank für die Beantwortung der
Fragen von mir und der Community danke
schön vielen Dank bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss
ja ich gucke zum Abschluss hier noch mal
in Eure Gemütslage und eure Kommentare
hier sagt zum Beispiel domwall auf
Youtube einen sehr gefährlicher Schritt
das ganze es geht aber nicht um die
lächerliche Anzahl von vier Flugzeugen
sondern allein um diesen Schritt und
Karl Händler Sohn sagt auf Facebook
reine Symbolik die vier Flieger
verändern gar nichts ja wie sich die
Situation weiter entwickelt wird wir
werden da auf jeden Fall dran bleiben
für euch und ich sehe hier gerade noch
danke für eure 19:30 Uhr Streams und
danke für die Kommentare Möglichkeit
hier da sage ich Danke für Eure
Kommentare und dass ihr immer so fleißig
in den Chat schreibt wir sehen uns
wieder bei ZDF heute live wenn ihr mögt